Now that you understand algorithms and
data structures,
it's time to think about
the actual interview.
For this lesson,
we're joined by a very special
guest to help us to do just that.
Welcome, Horatio.
>> Hello, I'm Horatio, and
I'm an Android coach here at Udacity.
Not too long ago,
I was in a similar situation to
the one you may be in right now.
I never took a class in college about
data structures and algorithms.
But I just graduated from
a UDacity Nanodegree, was preparing for
technical interviews.
Learning about data structures and
algorithms made me feel more
confident about technical interviews.
But I soon realized what is also very
important is the actual process for
answering an algorithm
question in an interview.
>> Definitely.
When an interviewer asks you a question,
your ability to get the right answer is
just a small part of
what they're evaluating.
They also want to see your
approach to solving problems and
your communication skills.
>> In this lesson,
you'll be shown interviews, and
then we'll break them down at each step
to help you understand exactly what
the interviewee is doing right and
wrong.
Then you will be able to implement
the interviewees' skills while avoiding
their mistakes.
>> The path to a successful algorithm's
interview involves a seven-step process,
which we'll go over in further
detail throughout the lesson.
>> The steps are Clarifying the
Question, Generating Inputs and Outputs,
Generating Test Cases, Brainstorming,
Runtime Analysis, Coding, and Debugging.
So let's get right into
it with our interview.